do you remember the clock set yeah
remember what Sam did and he almost
broke the camera I remember it like it
was yesterday not well the problem is
Sam has a way of communicating welcome
to day one of corridor digital shoes
smarter SmartWatch we are at Meg's clock
shop which is really just a garage and a
guest house that has clock into noodles
Sam and camera just arrived it and we're
gonna get things going five percent of
plan time we need to get to like 90
percent before we can really start doing
anything today so my first priority is
just figuring out everything the old
natural blue what what what what what do
you take us for what oh man all right
let's bring Sam came over we had a whole
discussion about when we're gonna help
scribe and then course it was like cams
over with his grubby fingers starts
putting them all over this box you know
how hey you know how opening things is
in this studio saw the way you looked at
her drama for the camera this is
authentic
[Applause]
it says is that electric scooter
oh this is the scooter yes I don't think
this is a scooter
why be spelling is not the hub motor
skateboard I know this one yeah dude
leveling up dude every board we get is
like better than the last one subscribe
electric long boards yeah I think it's
time we learn how to ride these it's
fixed o'clock the other day and the
hands were about quarter of an inch long
so I took hands like that and used
little file and scissors and made hands
for the clock because they don't make
hands that are quarter inch long anymore
I mean tools that you can't buy anymore
grinders and stuff I made my fiancée's
engagement ring for my wife that's
pretty cool really you can't buy this
stuff these are all for boring out holes
and stuff so you have brooches that we
don't cutter you can buy these tools
anymore they don't make these kind of
tools they'll make these but not like
they usually like 50 years ago guys you
gotta like these are gonna last another
thousand years the ones they make now
last you you know five or six and
they'll break and you'll buy new ones
yeah it's a consumer society I've got
all these old files and stuff build over
by do do we need a work that's like this
at the studio so if you're wondering how
we locked in this clock location I
worked with the company called rat pal
calm the Airbnb of locations basically
what we did was did a little research
found the clock shop and rap I was great
in getting their profile set up
coordinating the whole schedule to make
sure we can get in and get out smoothly
for our shoots your ever live in a bind
and looking for a location definitely
check out rapid comm we've been getting
a lot of
bull hitting us up about Electric
skateboards like the boosted board
this one is flexible looks a lot like
the x-ray this one goes real good charge
this up dog not send us turn a little
baby power right away I can tell that
this isn't as responsive as the booster
board or in the x-ray but you don't
really know until I take a fourth street
find out you ready no
wake up a little shoulders bunny could
get loosey-goosey
let me see you say sweet Zen hyzer
microphone we're gonna use today
it gets more of the deeper side of your
voice beautiful you use it yeah yeah we
use it on the vlog when we use the GH
five so if we shoot sixteen by nine
we're able to put end cards at the end
of the video those things that you can
click on yeah if we shoot on a wider
more anamorphic looking aspect ratio we
cannot put n cards on a video what
YouTube does not support it this way
when you watch tiny guns it has black
bars on there a full screen rather than
actually being properly fullscreen I
thought that was the whole point was
you're gonna try to get the anamorphic
look I am part of that as having the
boat the Boca properly which already
makes it look very interesting it looks
this is gonna look everything's gonna go
oh wow oh wow being able to just ride
for several miles walk into any store or
restaurant carrying your vehicle you
never have to worry about parking
yeah about falling and hurting myself
you get used to that yeah the serpent W
Oh God how many boards do we have enough
I've got a few that longer tail so you
can turn it but this braking is
dangerous you can't brake on it gentle
and nice for a man like me I'm on the
way to get a sandwich I don't know about
long boards in general go to a boot camp
I could actually own boarding boot camp
yeah don't touch don't touch it
dude it's like Ted say another man's
wife all right so
there's a black bishop friends there you
did the rest of the year so if it's a
game we have going on I think no no I
think it has something to do with this
word right here yes you also have the
this fun shot right here the restart
with them versus what we see here we go
so that's four setups door busts captain
set up Justin so then we're over here
we're with Jake we have four setups down
here eight a little ad work and three
two one action
never Charlie don't remember what Sam
did and he almost broke the camera Sam
has a way of communicating that isn't
always clear with everyone else but by
dictation I'm acting so I'm focusing on
acting Sam's with camera our Michael's
helping them out getting the lights and
stuff set up and Sam just stops and he
goes oh I'm about to make a boo-boo and
we're like what have us we don't have a
spreader for the tripod so each time we
set it up unless we're outside and like
dirt where stuff were these little
spikes little hubs whatever you can call
whatever you want to call them because
the tripod is not yeah we don't have a
spreader and it doesn't have feet it was
on concrete slippery concrete so you
know slipped out she slips I put it down
I was like you know there's probably
gonna slip and then it slipped and go
over and it was like a lifetime between
the moment
I saw it falling and the moment where we
stopped it from falling but it was all
good or so I think this is like another
one of those like oh so here's the funny
here's the funny part Sam the camera is
actually broken because that he's just
never noticed
fortunately the camera barely scuffed
the the table car Michael didn't you
grab it yeah car Michael grabbed it just
in time clothes on camera the red the
lenses one of the signals did something
get prescribed oh yeah yeah yeah and
that's the best the best part is that we
had prototype we had prototype cinema
prime lenses on there not a ton of ways
to recreate those no so what so what
you drop the fifty thousand dollar
camera wasn't the experimental prototype
cinema lens yes I know I don't feel that
bad about it you don't you don't feel
bad about it I mean I knew this I knew I
was gonna have it I literally said right
before I was like this is probably gonna
go bad I'm sorry I'm not more surprised
but like the surprise was the ruin to
the moment I set the tripod down I knew
the situation I was getting into I mean
I feel bad a little bit after the fact
because you know now I'm caught in the
act and this clips making it onto the
Internet and yeah so like I am a little
ashamed I guess in the future I
shouldn't let it happen in those moments
you don't really think you just kind of
react on instinct knowing that I was too
far from the camera to do anything
I just watched it's like watching a
train wreck here I'm gonna give you a
little bit more of an in-depth review of
what I do and do not like about each of
the boards what I do not like about them
is that they are not the one wheel what
we have here are two different Electric
skateboards one is called the serpent W
from a company called quick wheel the
other is called the backfired Galaxy g2
from backfire they were crowdfunded we
got early review copies they are both
hub motor wheels the motors are inside
the wheels we can sing that a lot lately
both relatively affordable board I think
the serpent W is like five or six
hundred dollars and the back fire to
board is like 400 bucks
pretty good compared to say a boosted
board which is like $1600 so it's
literally a quarter of the price
honestly I'm quite impressed with this
board not gonna lie what I want Electric
skateboards I want to be able to go at
least 20 miles an hour now for range
bare minimum you gotta have ten miles of
ranch
that's my opinion ideally you have 20
miles of range so you can go really far
distances or just not charge that off
for me the rule of thumb is I want to be
able to go 20 miles an hour for 20 miles
I have one complaint about this board
and that's the braking is a little too
sensitive it almost knocked me off a
couple times like how do I describe the
braking little too harsh up front the
initial braking is a little too harsh it
kind of like jumps on you really quickly
so the moment we kind of just even tap
the brakes it's like it slows down so
fast so quickly that you're just like
good which fortunately can be easily
done with just a quick little firmware
update updating the the software and the
s-curve of the acceleration profile of
motors I have a lot of mixed feelings
about the serpent w here's the thing the
thing is super heavy because the whole
thing is made out of metal but they're
advertising this board is a very safe
board they have lots of lights on check
out these lights so we got white lights
and if you are exploring for it kind of
go
Sooni put on the brakes red lights eat
right red red red red that's actually
pretty nice it's nice to have lights on
your board as I've learned from grinding
the woman all the time and it's even got
a front light here I mean you can buy
aftermarket license put on your electric
skateboard I really recommend shred
lights
those are great lights a lot of this
sounds great in theory the lights are
cool and all but honestly at the end of
the day I don't care about that I want
performance an electric skateboard and
this isn't doing it for me so it does
have the same top speed and range as
this paper here but this has like almost
no acceleration it's the slowest board
to get to that top speed I've ever
ridden a floor prom with the quick
wheels surfing w is that the braking is
so not sensitive it's practically not
there there is that at least twice when
I when I did my test right where I
slowed down and I couldn't slow down
fast enough a little sketchy when you're
going over 20 miles an hour it's all
electronically controlled with software
and I would like to have a lot more
responsive braking out of this board
having a handle on a skateboard is a
fantastic idea and I support that a
hundred percent however when your board
weighs like 20 pounds and it's just
laser-cut out of metal like this it cuts
your board the very first thing I do
would buy like that grip tape you put
them like baseball bats and just wrap up
these things here cuz then you can hold
it this one if you if you just throw on
the brakes and you're not prepared for
it you're not like a seasoned vet or
anything
you'll they there are two different
driving modes there's eco mode and sport
mode eco mode being it goes slower sport
mode being it goes faster and in theory
has more aggressive braking however I
found that on both the braking is just
the opposite of aggressive I do not know
if quick wheel is doing that
intentionally and they specifically
design that s-curve to have a really
slow braking if that is the case I
implore you to re-evaluate that decision
that's my review the two boards this
would have been the dopest thing ever
I hate being harsh on companies
especially when it's an addressable
problem that you can change like with a
software update I do think it is worth
mentioning that in its current and I
don't even know if this is final
firmware at all because they haven't
even started shipping these two backers
yet but I strongly feel that they need
to put some sort of padding on the
handles cuz I will not use the handles
without it because it literally cuts my
hand everyone always says it's like
watching a train wreck but I've never
actually watched a train wreck so
thank me has anyone watched a train
wreck everyone always uses that term as
if it's like second nature to everybody
else like watching a train wreck like
I'm so hungry I get either I mean but
who's ever done that not me if I don't
do anything this today is gonna be like
a train wreck so I better get to work